chris mannix the uh senior sports uh
illustrated writer covering the nba
joins us on the program the big question
here mannix is
how surprised are you the clippers let
doc rivers go
you know surprised not shocked
um you know the disappointing way
with which the clippers ended their
season there were a lot of people
that i talked to throughout the nba that
wondered if doc rivers
was going to survive um you know it was
pointed out to me by several
uh different league types that he had
taken that team exactly as far
as vinnie del negro had taken that team
uh
never being out of that second round to
blow a 3-1 lead
for the second time it begged the
question i did think because
of the whole bubble environment that you
know doc would get a chance to run it
back remember
you know this team before the pandemic
hit dan had won eight of the last nine
games
uh going into the break they were
starting to play their best basketball
of the season
then the bubble hits they have all sorts
of problems in orlando
i thought that would all be factored in
and doc would get another chance but
uh steve ballmer who had his
fingerprints all over this
ultimately decided to go in a different
direction do you think the clippers know
who their next
coach will be i don't um
you know largely because of the length
of this process
if they had let go of doc two days
three days after the end of the season i
might have thought they had a plan in
mind
um as it stands it took almost two weeks
for them to agree to part ways which
suggests there were some
you know some internal conversations
there i mean i i noted
you know in a piece i wrote for side.com
that you know lawrence frank's name was
nowhere near this
arts frank is the team president you
know usually the team president
makes decisions like this this was all
uh attributed to steve ballmer the owner
of the clippers so
i mean i think they have some ideas and
we can talk about them but
i don't think they have a clear
successor in mind
because you have ty lue there on the
bench and he's a
viable candidate for a couple of
openings there but is he
can he be part of you know the positive
here or was he also part of the negative
here as well
well tai lu makes the most sense because
going into
what is likely going to be uh either a
shortened season
or certainly a season that has a lot of
a lot of issues going into it with with
the pandemic
you probably want to try to have
as few bumps along the way as possible
smooth a transition
as possible and tyloo being there all
season long would make it a relatively
smooth transition from one coach to
another
the question i have about ty lue is that
would he want to take this job now tai
has been elevated to a job before of
course
you know taking the job after david
blatt was fired in cleveland
but this is an entirely different
situation doc rivers
is ty lue's mentor doc rivers is the guy
that brought ty lue
into the fold this year and made him one
of the highest paid assistant coaches
in basketball so would ty feel
differently
about assuming doc's chair than he would
taking david black's spot
that that's something i and other people
across the nba
uh have wondered as this sort of plays
out and i also wondered too
i wasn't surprised at all that doc was
fired i think that we really like
doc but if you look at his resume with
the clippers um you know he hasn't
performed
up to the standards of an elite coach
and then you look at paul george and you
look at kawhi leonard and they got one
more year
there before they can be you know free
agents here
do they have to co-sign on this does
steve ballmer say to kawhi
i'm gonna do this or i don't know if
they're
brought in in a decision-making role
here
well all star players have
some role in the hiring of a coach we
just saw that
with steve nash being hired in brooklyn
you know effectively getting kevin
durant's
seal of approval with that team it's
just a question of how involved
they get in the process so i do believe
kawhi leonard
and paul george will be brought into
this process and
they'll be given a chance to to voice
their feelings and their thoughts
on who the next head coach is all that
being said dan and
this is more me my opinion on this i i
look at the doc rivers firing
as a staggering overreaction at this
point i get what you're saying
about how his teams have underachieved
in the playoffs i mentioned the two
blown leads in the postseason but this
was such
a unique environment and this was such a
difficult
situation to succeed i mean it was
difficult for everybody
not the least of which was the denver
nuggets who had similar problems to the
clippers
but the clippers came into the bubble
with like half a team
they they went through their seating
games with montrez harold in and out
patrick beverly in and out lou williams
the whole magic city thing
uh with him harold didn't play his first
game until they got to
uh to the postseason patrick beverly
missed all but one game
of that first round i mean there are no
excuses for blowing a 3-1 lead
but i don't know how you look at this uh
this experience
and what happened the bubble is saying
it's proof positive that doc rivers
can't coach this team i would actually
look
at what the clippers were doing
pre-pandemic when load management seemed
to be working for them when the the team
seem to be peaking
at just the right time that to me is
stronger
there's a stronger reason to bring doc
rivers back
than what happened in the bubble to fire
he's chris mannix senior nba writer for
sports illustrated you floated out the
idea that maybe the clippers
do a drive-by with phil jackson you
think phil is
physically capable of being a head coach
in the nba
i think that's the biggest question 75
years old just turned 75
this month uh has dealt with myriad
health issues
uh over the years can his body hold up
to
uh the rigors of an nba season i think
that's that's the first and foremost
question
that that would have to be answered when
it comes to phil jackson but
other than that dan it it does make a
lot of sense to at least kick the tires
on phil jackson i mean how many coaches
out there
are proven to have one at this level who
can take over
teams with star players and succeed
at the highest level i know a lot of
people will say the triangle
is outdated in today's nba game i
disagree i think that phil's offense
can work in today's nba game i think guy
like kawhi leonard
could actually thrive in it in the same
way kobe bryant uh thrived in it with
the lakers and if you're phil
jackson isn't this job a little bit
appealing to you
don't don't you aren't there reasons to
go and take this job dan i mean dan it's
been like a decade i know that
relationship with genie busses
is still strong but a decade ago the
lakers didn't exactly you know throw
filler retirement party
on his way out the door it didn't end in
the most positive of ways
with the lakers feels comfortable living
in l.a
uh being in that environment and phil
even though he's the all-time
leader in championships can do something
or at least have the opportunity
to do something with the clippers that
no other coach has done and that's when
three championships with three teams as
a head coach so
if you're phil jackson your body's first
and foremost but if it could hold up
and the clippers call i'd make a run at
him and it doesn't help the clippers
situation that the lakers are four wins
away from another title
no it doesn't but if you're phil
doesn't that add a little bit more fuel
to the fire
like the lakers might be the champion
this time next week
they're going to be looking to run it
back next year with the same group
the chance to to walk into staples
center
and win the championship like dan you
know
phil jackson you've talked to him over
the years i i know him a little bit i've
talked to him over the years
you can't tell me that this possibility
is not at least a little bit appealing
to phil jackson
there are other variables like i don't
know how he and jerry west would ever
get yeah
that was that organization that was
another question because
jerry and phil that didn't end well
either it didn't but
i mean jerry's not the general manager
with that team he's influential but he
is more of an advisor at this stage and
a well-paid one
at this stage but it's not like he's
running the organization
i think look if you're steve ballmer and
you're not convinced that ty lose the
guy
and you're not convinced jeff van
gundy's the guy or somebody else that
you have in mind
you've basically got a blank check that
you can write your head coach
why not take the uh the microsoft jet up
to montana and see what phil jackson's
thinking
how do the heat win the finals
i mean i i throw out to a degree the 2-0
record
in the regular season because those
games were played
without jake crowder without andre
wadala who both acquired the trade
deadline
uh tyler hero was playing behind
kendrick nunn at that point of the
season they were very early games
uh in the in the season so i don't look
at that as being a variable
i do think that the fact that anthony
davis has
dominated a bio in these matchups is a
factor davis average close to 30 points
per game
against the heat shot about 60 from the
floor i guess the heat where out of bio
has gone the completely opposite
direction he has about 11.5 points per
game
are the second lowest against any team
in the nba
during the season how they win this
series is if adebayo can even up that
matchup
if he can play the way he played against
the celtics i think crowder and iguodala
can cause some problems for lebron i
think that zone defense if they throw it
at the lakers
can cause some problems for some of
those shooters but if anthony davis
plays the same way against bam adebayo
uh as he did during the regular season
adebayo vice versa
could be a quick series from miami
always great to talk to you chris thank
you
you got it dan chris mannix senior nba
writer from sports illustrated